bonjour denis gravouil merci de répondre
à nos quelques autos ce matin il ya déjà
eu un premier recours devant le conseil
d'état en décembre
le texte a été retoqué alors pourquoi ce
tir groupé syndicales ce matin devant le
conseil d'état à nouveau justement parce
que la réforme est toujours aussi
injuste la première procédure nous avait
permis de gagner d'annuler faire annuler
en partie le mode de calcul qui est
partie ment violent et le gouvernement a
revu sa copie mais finalement pas tant
que ça et il maintient que sa réforme
c'est une réforme qui va faire 1,15
million deux perdants ça veut dire au
1er juillet si toutes ces personnes
toutes ces personnes qui sont au chômage
par exemple des intérimaires des
intermittents de l'emploi de toutes
sortes par exemple des saisonniers vont
se retrouver avec une baisse de location
extrêmement importante c'est 20 % en
moyenne
mais ça peut être comme c'est une
moyenne ça peut être quasiment la
disparition d'une allocation chômage
pour des absurdités aussi grande que un
contrat qui commence le 15 du mois plus
tôt que le premier ça peut faire perdre
toutes les allocations chômage on est
d'utiliser le mot absurdité
je vais le réutiliser dans la sémantique
de la ministre du travail
elisabeth board je cite les syndicats
nous impute les absurdités du système
qu'ils ont eux-mêmes construit en
contestant les nouvelles règles ils
défendent un système d'hyper flexibilité
ce sont les mots donc d'elisabeth bornes
qu'est ce que vous lui répondez pas deux
choses d'une part le système il n'est
pas forcément parfait il faut
l'améliorer en améliorant les droits des
chômeurs mais l'absurdité elle vient
bien du fait que les nouvelles règles
imposées par le gouvernement en
s'articulant avec les anciennes règles
qui marchait plutôt pas mal se sont
retrouvés à créer de nouvelles
inégalités extrêmement flagrante des
inégalités dans l'ancien système
il y en avait des petites et là ils sont
multipliées par 50 pour certaines
personnes
et puis quant à la paire flexibilité ce
sont les réformes du milieu du droit du
travail et notamment les ordonnances
macron qui ont accru la flexibilité qu
ont permis aux entreprises de pouvoir
recourir à des contrats à durée
déterminée de plus en plus courts et
c'est ça la raison c'est pas parce qu'on
est une assurance chômage que on va
chercher les emplois pour les gens
recherchent des emplois stables et quand
ils n'en trouvent pas ils prennent des
cdd et quand ils n'ont pas de travail
il dort a droit à une allocation chômage
et c'est ce qui est en train de
supprimer la ministre du travail et le
gouvernement général l'ex premier
ministre edouard philippe avait dit que
les règles d'indemnisation ainsi trop
souvent au maintien d'emplois précaires
et pas suffisamment au retour à l'emploi
alors faut-il ou non cette réforme mais
c'est pas les règles d'indemnisation au
chômage qui empêche les gens de
retrouver du boulot il ya eu la
meilleure preuve en est que il y a déjà
six chômeurs sur dix qui ne sont pas
indemnisés il ya ceux parmi les gens qui
sont inscrits à pôle emploi y a 6
millions d'inscrits et là que 2.4
millions qui sont indemnisés donc les
gens cherchent du travail c'est bien
connu on cherche pas à vivre d'une
allocation chômage qui ne dure pas
longtemps
on cherche du travail et puis on a le
droit normalement à une allocation
chômage supprimer les allocations
chômage ça ne pas me faire que
qu'enfoncer les gens dans l'endettement
et dans la pauvreté
on a déjà un million de pauvres de plus
grâce à la politique de mener de macron
depuis qui est arrivé est là là c'est
cette réforme elle va enfoncer les gens
dans la précarité et c'est pas en leur
supprimant les allocations chômage
on va les aider à trouver du boulot
quand tu n'as pas l'ex ministre du
travail ne rien le panicaut à l'origine
de cette réforme estime pour sa part
qu'il faut poursuivre les discussions
avec les partenaires sociaux pour mieux
l'adapter au contexte actuel de crise
comment est ce que vous êtes
accueillez ce soutien surprise soutien
attention à ce qu'on dit parce que c'est
quand même elle qui a inventé cette
réforme de l'assurance chômage qui est
absolument absurde
bon là elle en train de torpiller sa
successeur est en train mais dont au
moins il est en train de dire que c'est
absurde de la faire maintenant nous ont
dit que c'est absurde de la faire tout
le temps même quand elle voulait la
faire parce que baisser les droits des
chômeurs ça n'a jamais permis de pousser
les gens à trouver du travail toutes les
études le montrent quand on est au
chômage on fait tout ce qu'on peut pour
trouver du boulot ou alors on est
découragés et il faut être aussi aider
et puis c'est pas henry pearson le
connais suffisamment bien les règles
d'assurance chômage pour pour optimiser
et vivre aux frais de la princesse c'est
une légende qui est entretenue pour
détruire les droits sociaux toutes les
études sérieuses le montre le
relancement de la cftc à s'engager dans
cette procédure est ce que ça peut avoir
une influence non je n'avais aucune la
cftc elle fait ce qu'elle veut mais tous
les autres syndicats yvon et surtout le
conseil d'état a jugé en droit et va
constater que entre deux personnes
il ya des inégalités flagrantes je
prends un exemple si vous avez un
intérimaire qu'on appelle pour un
contrat pendant ce temps dans le mois
d'avril et puis qu'il a dû choses une à
moi de chômage derrière il sera payé un
mois il sera indemnisé un mois et puis
c'est l' agence d'intérim vous rappelle
en vous disant ah bah non finalement
votre contrat il est décalée de 15 jours
vous travaillez du 15 au 15 mai la vous
avez toujours un mois de salaire au même
tarif est par contre vous avez plus de
chômage denis gravouille si la réforme
entre bel et bien en vigueur le 1er
juillet s'il n'y a pas de suspension en
urgence comme vous le désirez
qu'est ce que vous prévoyez de faire au
courant du mois de juillet ce qu'il va y
avoir des mouvements de manifestation il
y aura des mouvements il ya déjà des
lieux culturels qui sont équipés je suis
il sera occupé par dont je vous savez
cuir sur la cgt spectacle et je suis
aussi en charge du dossier assurance
chômage pour l'ensemble de la cgt mais
évidemment on n'a pas l'intention de
désarmer contre cette réforme
la bataille juridique c'est une chose la
bataille politique et syndicale elle va
se poursuivre tout au long de l'été et
éventuellement à la rentrée parce que
c'est à la rentrée que certains bon ben
on découvrira à quel point leurs
allocations vont être baissés ou
supprimés il faut absolument faire
annuler cette réforme les éclés les
batailles sont parfois longues mais j'ai
bon espoir devant le conseil d'état
merci donner grave on est d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes le secrétaire général de la
cgt spectacle